有任何一个男人喜欢跟自己的高中班主任、
初中班主任天天逼他学习，
逼他上进，
逼他创业，
逼他一定要优秀，
逼他一定要出人头地，
没有哪个男的愿意跟班主任过日子。
我今年30岁了，
我是体制内的老师，
我的年收入加上本地的人才补贴的话，
一年有18个，
我现在名下是无房无车的，
我现在的对象呢，
比我小一岁，
他的父母包括他都是经商的，
我们在一起的时候就是疫情那年，
他跟我有透露过他嫁的其中一个公司交易额为一个小目标，
这样子我现在纠结的点要不要结婚，
是因为我们今年要准备订婚结婚，
但是越到这个时候，
我不确定是我自己的心态问题，
还是真的是现实两个人之间的问题。
第一点呢，
就是今年是第5年的交往时间了，
但是我们相互之间其实都有存在一些猜疑和不信任对方，
第2点呢，
我建议的点就是我希望对方出去跟朋友聚餐也好，
或者是出差也好，
可以有稍微详细的报备，
但是他呢，
不是喜欢实时性的报备，
就可能是事后他才说，
或者是过了一段时间他才会说，
还有就是觉得他相比我而言。
不是那么成熟，
我们已经同居了几年，
在生活上他是比较懒的，
所有的家务是我做，
他会做饭，
如果我开口想要吃什么，
不给我吃，
但是其他的收尾的工作都是我做。
从我考上这个工作以来，
他就在我学校的附近买了一套房，
专门给我住，
是一个小平方的，
就从住进来到现在，
所有的水电全部是他付，
就相当于我住在自己家的一样。
介意的一个点是他不给我看他的手机，
但是我有偷偷看过，
没有一次是开心的出来的，
但也没有抓到一些实质性的行为，
就看到他跟他的同学聊天，
但是默认他自己单身的情况，
可能那个同学跟他关系不是很好，
我带他见过我的朋友，
我的家人，
我的同辈，
所有人都觉得我是属于很强势的那一方，
因为可能是工作原因，
又又兼班主任，
我自我感觉在感情中是处于弱势的一方，
他是一个拒绝沟通的人，
但是我这个人又是一个表达欲很强的人，
所以这点我是犹豫的。
还有就是我们住在一起期间，
我生病的情况下，
有一次就是他因为玩游戏玩到凌晨，
我那个时候正好肠胃炎发作，
我想让他送我去医院，
还是我自己打车去医院的，
他不愿意送你还是怎么的，
他说你能不能让我睡一会会儿？
我实在太困了，
因为那个时候他是刚结束游戏，
就是他自己现在是自由职业，
但是跟他自己家里的公司是有一些往来的，
他一般如果有出差在外工作，
我也陪他出差或确实是辛苦的，
但没有出差工作在家就是玩游戏，
甚至更过分的，
就有时候是陪他颠倒的玩，
但是我觉得这个如果对我没什么影响的话，
我好像也是能接受的，
就是这样。
你见过他父母了吗？
我见过他的家里，
外婆家等等都去过，
你感觉他们家对你满意吗？
是非常满意。
我的朋友说我的强势不仅仅是凌驾于男方，
甚至是凌驾于对方的家庭之上，
他们的父母对于我而言都是有求必应，
可以说是我想要的，
有开口提过的，
都都是满足的这一种。
比如你提了哪些要求他们能满足你呢？
我想买一辆车，
后来他们买了给我开车呀，
他在你单位附近买的那套小房子是多少钱呀，
算下来120是登记在你男朋友名下对不对？
是的，
车也是登记在你男朋友名下对不对？
其实我觉得这些都是外在的，
因为我自己可能家庭原因，
我是很想要一个属于我自己的房子，
我说我可以买房，
到时候婚后住我的房子，
我来付我房子的一切哦，
他说那也行，
然后他的想法就是婚后把这套。
嗯，
过户到我的名下，
用我的公积金来还，
其实我心里是偏拒绝的那一种啊，
生活上啊什么都可以，
但是很多细节上相处就会有摩擦，
我们适合走下去嘛，
我的妈妈在没有生病前，
我的爸爸他们两个关系很好，
但是他生病之后，
他们的关系就没有之前那么好，
所以我会害怕自己未来会走妈妈的老路。
其实我特别推荐你去看一些博主对于一个人物的分析，
这个人物是冷清秋，
金粉世家，
这个电视剧里面的冷清秋跟你现在的处境呢，
是有一点点像的啊，
就冷清秋她本身是一个读过书，
有过新观念，
她想自立自强，
比较清高的一个女孩子，
她处的那个对象呢，
就是官二代，
你的这个呢，
是富二代，
然后嫁过去了之后呢，
冷清秋的日子就过得特别拧巴，
她的拧巴的点在于什么呢？
因为她自己受过教育，
他很要强，
他想要自食其力，
想要通过自己的工作去赚钱，
不想要像官太太，
像官二代的这些夫人一样去玩儿啊，
去社交啊什么的，
他不愿意过那样的日子，
所以他跟家里面的所有的太太，
包括嫂嫂啊，
她关系都处的不是很好，
因为他用那种拒绝，
冷漠和我跟你们不一样，
其实建立了一堵墙，
其实某种程度上像你，
你跟他的父母去。
见面你也让他的父母感受到你的强势，
他本质是一样的，
本质是你清高，
你自尊心强，
但其实人家家庭条件比咱们好，
人家的财力经济实力比咱们要雄厚，
所以你某种程度上你要伪装出来，
我可能不在乎，
我可能不一定能瞧得上你呢，
其实内心还是因为我的经济实力没有你强，
所以我越是这样的话，
我越要自尊，
我越要在你家面前表现出来，
我很强势，
我不在乎钱，
就这那的啊，
日子过长了，
人就容易拧巴，
拧拧巴，
然后跟你生活在一起的人，
他也会拧巴。
所以今天我想跟你聊的话题是什么呢？
一定要去认真的去分析我自己性格的问题，
分析我自己想要的东西，
分析我自己性格的特色吧，
不一定说是问题，
因为自立自强，
他本身没毛病啊，
就自尊心强，
它本身都没有毛病，
但是要分析说我想要的生活是什么样子的，
如果说我想要的生活就是，
哎呀，
我们单位的女同事都羡慕我住180㎡的挑高的复式的房子，
我单位的这些女同事都羡我开几十万的车，
家里的娘家人也觉得我就是日子过得挺好的，
那就要收起我这份清高，
收起我对别人的赐，
我要客观的承认公公婆婆条件比我好，
我得拍公公婆婆的马屁，
我得在公公婆婆面前表现出来，
说哎呀，
你。
能看上我是我的荣幸，
我特别感恩公公婆婆，
这个买车了给我开，
哎呀，
我觉得在单位的话，
人家都很羡慕我能找到这样的公公婆婆，
你就是内心要接纳，
接纳我自己，
我就是优秀啊，
我就是条件好啊，
我就是找了一个财阀，
找了一个富二代，
富一代，
那么我在他们家的话，
我必须要打好这个关系，
打好这个关系的第一步就是承认人家比我有钱，
承认人家不管是基于运气，
基于时代的红利，
还是基于什么，
他就是比我有钱，
那我在他们面前的话，
就是要表现的出来，
嘴巴甜一点，
拍马屁拍的好一点，
要承认我就是有福气啊，
你看啊，
那个妈，
你看那么多人喜欢我老公当初，
哎呀你当时就选了我，
我就是有这个运气，
有这个福气，
就这那的一套马屁拍是吧，
就是他的父母没有这样的程度，
就是我们家族也是非常平等和谐的，
只不过就是我认为我是太喜欢这个男生了，
我会有那种刚谈恋爱时的那种热恋，
到现在的他口中的老夫老妻这样的落差感，
这样的落差感之下，
我就会多想，
然后我就去问问他吗？
他就会觉得问多了有什么意义呢？
什么你都已经知道了，
为什么还要问怎么样，
这样子就会容易吵架。
其他的方面我们其实是都已经是，
也就差不多，
因为我对什么婚礼啊那些我都没有高要求，
我就说差不多就行了，
也没有说我一定要怎么。
这样的，
包括彩礼也是，
就是说我也没有要多少，
我们家也是双倍赔回去的，
这样子的情况就是在意这个人值不值得我嫁，
其他的我觉得都好说这个人值不值得嫁，
这个人相处的好不好，
有的因果关系是互为因果的，
什么叫互为因果呢？
因为你自己是当老师的，
你当班主任的，
有很多时候我非常坦率的告诉你，
这个世界上的所有的男人，
没有谁愿意跟班主任过一辈子，
真的没有任何一个男人愿意跟自己的初中班主任，
高中班主任就过一辈子，
所以你必须要把你的职业身份和你的家庭身份一定要割裂开来，
明白就是在家收敛自己的，
对他就是互为因果，
你说我跟这个男的能不能过到老这个问题，
他是互为因果的，
他不光取决于这个男人性格怎么样，
还取决于我对这个男人的态度，
我对这段婚姻的态度怎么怎么样。
有一句话你一定要记住，
没有任何一个男人喜欢跟自己的高中班主任、
初中班主任天天逼他学习，
逼他上进，
逼他创业，
逼他一定要优秀，
逼他一定要出人头地，
没有哪个男的愿意跟班主任过日子，
这是第一。
第二，
如果你想好了要跟这家人在一起过日子的话，
就是接纳。
我觉得人家条件比我好一点，
所以在这个基础之上的话，
我没有必要假装清高，
用清高来作为。
戏去，
疏远去，
怎么怎么样，
好，
我明白了，
就这样啊，
好谢谢，
好拜拜。
我原来看那个冷清秋，
看那个金粉世家的时候，
我总感觉就是冷清秋跟他们家人就是格格不入，
但有的时候人家那些姨呀嫂子啊什么的，
没有出于恶意，
人家可能邀请你打个麻将啊，
邀请你喝个咖啡啊，
邀请你出去看个戏啊，
邀请你干点啥，
冷清秋就是拒绝他，
就是不愿意跟他们在一起。
年轻的时候看就总觉得他这人怎么这么拧巴呢，
怎么这样呢？
其实长大了之后明白他，
也理解他，
因为他是受过心式教育的嘛，
他对于女性的自立自强他是有向往的，
她不希望说我只是因为长得漂亮，
我只是因为嫁了个男人，
所以我就在这家人，
被这家人养着，
当一个寄生虫，
一样的被养着，
她不愿意过那样的日子，
我也理解她，
但是她不愿意过那样的日子的时候，
某种程度上，
他会穿上一身清高的像刺猬一样的这样一个衣服，
有的时候会把周遭的人不是恶意的东西会解读成恶意，
解读成他瞧不起我，
就是他有很多嫂嫂，
其实对他刚开始是没有什么恶意的，
但他容易太敏感了，
容易把别人的说的那些话就解读成好像是瞧不起他似的，
所以相处起来，
他在那个家里他就不快乐，
一旦有一天当这个男孩子对他的。
疫情褪去了之后，
尤其是啊，
怀孕啊，
生孩子啊，
当她发现这个男孩子没有刚初开始的时候追求她这么热烈的时候，
她一下子落差太大了，
因为在家里也觉得跟大家过得不快乐是吧？
这个男的也对我也没有以前这么好了，
他就这日子就没法儿往下过了，
刚才那个妹妹就可以多去听一听，
有很多博主在分析冷清秋他的性格，
他的处事风格，
你看跟你有没有一些相同类似的地方，
你看从冷清秋他处理人际关系的这个事儿上能不能找到一点说，
哎，
以后我要注意了，
我不能这么敏感啊，
我不能这么清高，
我不能这么跟人家好像是拉开这样的距离，
说那样的话似的哈，
就这意思啊，
记得点赞关注哦。